it
is about 8 and 1 half hours since uh I
was on
stream for 16
hours we are now
back got some sleep we are going to
figure
out what the hell is wrong with this
freaking
crazy Isaac Sim or is gym
simulator me just check 1
fine you know maybe we can actually do
something with
this we'll just do
this maybe some people are the new
joiners we start to
Puffer that would be good
let me get race stream open so I can
actually
see
morning back at
Dev
man I got some tea I'll wake up very
so this thing seg F so I'm second render
hey
Captain this is what we got done
yesterday it loads the robot in I think
that was quick enough for you to see
I'll do it again this is uh Isaac
Jim so it loaded the first frame
in uh I actually saw it the previous
time I've got a color randomizer on it
so that actually
ran
um but then the second time you call
render it crashes for some reason even
if you don't do anything else if you
just call render twice it uh it crashes
let me see if I can find if I can at
least pause it so you can see it
properly yeah so I'll just put a
breakpoint right
here okay so here's Isaac uh here is
Isaac Jim you can see that there are
other robots around here you can see
they're all going to be in this one
scene I can't click anything in this UI
uh
because you know it's not uh stepping
this
live but we have all the bot pieces
loaded in yeah this thing I really
doesn't like when you pause an app like
this stupid um
humanoid we've got the bots in
here so the question is why does calling
render twice fail
this first thing I'll just be to see if
GPT has this indexed
Graphics disable camera
sensors oh is this
it hold on so we have create
Sim and then we create the viewer
we set the up and we set the
camera and
[Music]
then in
would you mind looking at latest run
curves
yep
nice is this your shot accuracy I at
because it starts very low this is your
shot
accuracy shots
fired weapons pick
up how do they have 1.0 weapon
pickup is this just you start them with
a weapon or
something break time heavy break time
Epoch this looks good either
way got to get this
faster
200k get
faster we got neural MMO close to
500 other than that you're good this
looks like you got a pretty stable
environment good
job I got um by the way there's going to
be a thing in a couple of weeks I don't
know if you're interested I almost don't
want to tell you about it cuz I'd rather
have you do a science side stuff on
puffer but I figured you'd be
interested um so you've been seeing me
work on
this for a while and I've come to the
conclusion that their engine just is not
fast uh madona really isn't great for
this CU they've got like such a variable
number of cars and you need to have the
same number per SC so unless there's a
way around that I don't think this is a
good fit for this so we are discussing
with them porting this thing to C native
uh and then they'd be able to have demos
on the web it would be way faster they'd
be able to run like 20x faster
experiments most likely at least 10x
faster experiments they'd be able to use
uh puffer neoc carbs you know with the
new speed and all that and uh like major
contributors to the environment code
would be on any subsequent Publications
as authors so I don't know if you're
interested in that but that will
potentially be an
opportunity I'm only going to offer this
I think to you and Spencer based on your
contributions to puffer so far so that
will be on the
table though actually no has been doing
some cool stuff though I don't think he
has the
time is his uh his recent TC GPR was
actually very good code
so I will mention there I don't think he
I just don't get the time otherwise he
Still's gotten pretty good
you know what we're going to do with
this going to do
this this render method I want to know
exactly where this
viewer let's see what this is
it's like folded on the third time
around which is kind of weird oh no
maybe it was the second
well that doesn't freaking help now does
it
hey how's it
going D you need to get to sleep my
God I got like just shy of 8 hours and I
would have liked to have gotten like N9
or whatever but I don't know just woke
I have
uh this F this file
exist time being SCI side
sounds good by me I'm very happy to have
people on the science side speaking of
which you let me know on the continous
satari
stuff I have um I have some really good
ideas on carbs as well but I'm going to
need to find like a good 3 Days To just
work on carbs uh and ideally 3 days when
I'm fresh not three three days at the
end of a compl complete freaking code
bingee on crazy simulation
PR that is going to be such an awesome
end does it build for web
cuz if we can get that to build for web
what we should do is we should come up
with at least like we should come up
with a cool Shader for the
thing cool Shader or two and uh and get
that online as a demo that would be so
cool oh continuous Atari okay impulse
takes a
while all right can continuous Atari
stuff would be good to have we'll accept
that as well we also got I didn't even
check these this morning
so far none of these parameters have
found anything on
this oh it's centered at one end that's
probably bad
yeah I should kill this cuz look it's
determinization way too much it's doing
this but it actually it has no idea of
um it has no idea if these prams are any
good yeah shaders are good to pick up if
you've not done that um they're pain in
the ass but they're good to pick
up me for
hell
oh dude how does this [ __ ]
Branch there we go that should be at
four COI want to
make very much a
backand you got to think about some
stuff
yeah I think about things
I'd be surprised if this is enough to
actually do anything
anything why is it sample this cost
point up
here kind of crazy
should definitely be able to get
something out of this before then
M
ah I see
do well we I accidentally had it uh not
make enough
Ms so we'll see if that matters but uh
it's a it's pretty
finicky it's a hard M it's very
sensitive
it's very hard to get off the ground as
well with
it if you don't find something in those
initial random
samples um carbs and by extension neoc
carbs can't really do much so
you you know
that's something that we'll have to
tweak and adjust
I mean this wasn't terrible
like it tried some different batch
sizes it tried some very expensive runs
which was a little
odd uh it tried different learning rates
though did it go pretty it didn't go low
enough I don't think
yet maybe hold
on
that yeah that could help but I want to
try something first so we do
this I think the mean
is we add zero here oh
yeah that's
better let me try
this
okay and let me make sure it this
launched then we'll just leave this and
keep going on our stuff
there you
go all right so we'll leave this and
we'll keep going on
uh our personal version of hell
here so whatever setting this variable
did um screwed
up let me try something if I do I get
out of this
terminal I get into this terminal
render yes so now this
renders you get the
window if I hit continue I get the
render
yep um and then that variable there
there was a variable on the for that was
Go interesting so this isn't set but if
you set this it breaks
guy a lot of
info if I do
okay Nvidia I have NVIDIA drivers you
dummy
GL I'm on 550 so I don't know why you
did this
that's interesting that we have to do
that
I don't see the GPU
still let's see if that screws anything
sake stupid
stupid
this is why you don't just copy and
paste random [ __ ] off of uh off of
forums or actually was this jity
there we go get rid of that and we are
back
fine wait
seriously must enable
dude I really don't want to have to redo
this container
because Isaac is a pain in the
you know I knew that that one was like a
bad idea I don't know why I freaking did
that I mean I didn't know if
legitimately that would have been
needed GPU pipeline do do I have torch
working
oh wait I do have Cuda working so what
the hell's wrong with
this oh maybe it's that uh maybe it's
that Vulcan file hold on
and this is incred I'm going to have to
remake this [ __ ]
container oh that actually worked for
now I don't know how that managed to I
don't know how I managed to screw that
up but whatever so here are Bots and
then we get our okay so we're back to
where we started at least
Vulcan so I imagine this is probably the
wrong the wrong thing because
you know it's possible these configs are
just so old that uh they no longer apply
to Modern
systems I'm going to be back in about 10
minutes I do a couple quick
right oh hey you made a
I you made or you already had an X
account oh shoot we still have these
bugs to
fix yeah we have some leads I
guess
this run time equal in do I have this
ARG
let me see if I have this
ARG I don't have Nvidia in
dude how [ __ ] stupid is this thing if
you don't mind restarting the container
you can delete the
container this is why this [ __ ] is bad
it's like if you don't know what you're
doing you just break everything cuz it's
just dumb
do you see how stupid this thing is it
literally gave me a new container
okay well they're freaking wrong because
look this doesn't even
have this doesn't even have Nvidia in
there so this is just stupid so I'm
going to close this tab before it makes
me waste more
time did you know that they're spending
a 100 uh was it $500 billion on this
[ __ ] definitely AGI
and
moronic Network host GP is
all X11 forwarding I think I have
this right
so yeah I have the X11
forward
it
display well the display Works otherwise
I wouldn't get anything it's not the
display it's not that flag
um let me
think is it possible this isn't a render
error and that this is like actually
something in the
code it's going to drive me absolutely
insane
integer is
required default drive
mode asset
options let me go look up asset options
default mode to use actual actuate
joints drive mode
joints let me make sure I didn't copy it
wrong um
I'll just make sure I didn't copy it
wrong from
equals do mode none so this is getting
set here
I just
[Music]
continue just do
this and we said Vault
so not getting any errors let me see if
I run it without the break point if that
changes
anything this this is the only thing I
get and this is what was set in the
previous thing I don't know if this is a
problem what if I just put zero here
what
right the weird thing is it renders one
frame
thing oh hang
on maybe I've been stupid here
refresh if not self. viewer
it shouldn't be super s.m. render like
do so we do
one and we get the
Bots and we do two and it's seg BS
m.
render doesn't
render so the simulate doesn't freaking
maybe you are meant to have to simulate
before you
render hang
stable okay that's that's stable because
it's not doing anything though
right so we got self M
step so this does run the simulator
forward
refresh
Sim observations don't need to be
computed this is fine so we do
false I don't actually set up render
here do
on I do render here so what if we do
what if we do with out
right okay so this opens up the window
but it doesn't actually draw anything to
it and now this does not break it only
breaks when you call render
twice which is very odd
it breaks right here on draw
viewer what's the uh the true on
that step graphics on the Sim and then
draw viewer crashes h
the problem is I don't even know if this
is a Sim
screen which is
interesting and we get the bot
here uhhuh so something's screwing up I
think with the SIM because
if I render it after 10 steps I have an
empty
probably I don't know what it could
possibly be
that they have this thing set to false
which is kind of
weird super do render on sync frame
time so I think this goes into task
space
sync frame
time oh and they don't even use
it wait
enable viewer
time I'm trying to think
what what is needed
here all right let's try to get the
actions
maybe to not crash
I'm trying to think is there just extra
stuff I need to call to make this s work
because everything is loaded
in let me see
very interesting that it's still widely
used well apparently the thing that they
replaced it with is more of even more of
a pain in the
ass
um
yeah look we're open to adding bindings
for all sorts of stuff this is for a
client this is what they want this is
what we're going to use it's still
widely used research is still being
published on this
we just have to figure out how to get
this thing working
so I mean we
have this
code for our base task as
is pre physics physics and post physics
is how they do this all right and then
we do
task then we look for their
step they have a step and they have a
render but
they their step also calls
it right so here's the
pre-step is this which I think we have
right we
targets hang on do we not have
this actions to PD
targets oh yeah yeah cuz this is that
function and then we unwrap the
n and then the post step has a refresh
tensor the observation stuff doesn't
call we have a render which
is update camera that shouldn't matter
matter I think we just have a update
camera in our render though yeah so this
is this is update camera this is the
code for that
is there any way I can just see where
it's SE
fting I
uh I mean I'm kind of it's kind of going
to be horrifying to run this with GDB
do I just have to put this in
here where it
belongs and I got to do like
okay this is this is probably right here
this is probably the
thing welcome YouTube folks we're
working on something that will be very
cool but at the moment is terrible
terrible
debugging trying to get Isaac Jim
very nice and cleanly running with
puffer lib with half of the code of
what's typically needed for
okay that's not how you install that but
yep that's
installed it's really insistent on this
flag including Vulcan
I don't think I need that flag
Vulcan drivers were at
[Music]
version is you get these
drivers okay so this is
actually is that what Ian was
required until this
oops okay that's still seg fult so that
doesn't
help Vulcan
tools
set though I might have forgotten to set
them in this shell so let's do that
info okay we're still not still not
finding this
because of this
old so I don't know if this is the
problem but definitely this not find
finding the
GPU these are the only two
errors ah and wait we have skipping ICD
as
well so that's not getting
loaded so I think
I think I do need to set these
paths which was hold on this is what it
looked like
before let me see if I can find the uh
the issue
this yeah I
do
eat so we're just going to
do copy
messages because we still don't
have uh
Nvidia we still don't have this Library
path so that seems important I don't
know that like uh that's not an error I
think that is important
dumbass checked installation path of
Optics and
Vulcan shouldn't need
do I have this
anywhere no I
reinstall the Nvidia driver but this
isn't a container
need to ensure the three Jon files
exist oh lovely this is
uh yeah so that's not going to
help I don't have this file on my system
what
seems some
files would be me okay hold
unfortunately so I think what I'm going
to do
I'm going to commit the current stuff
we're going to try
this we're not going to get rid of our
current
I think we won't have to do too much
because all we have to do is see if uh
if
Vulcan can see the GPU so I don't think
it's going to be that bad because if
Vulcan can't see the GPU then there's no
point and we won't have to go through
the whole thing so yeah let's do that um
copy Das R
Isaac
coppery R
we okay so we're going to put the Isaac
J into the docker so we can go deal with
that if we need oh yeah also we want to
add
tank okay so we got a new new tank
here and uh we
we shouldn't even need to get python 38
uh just to test this we should literally
just need to
do yeah so we should just have to do
this
registry and uh I forgot the renders
have to be run these have to be run from
within
info okay so that's not uh not there we
haven't done this
yet no we get the same two issues oh but
I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] because I forgot to
add the the flag so I just made the
exact same
text you know it can't actually find
those Mesa a driver so maybe they're
somewhere else and messing stuff up I'm
going to look into that as
well
um we have some options
see okay so this still isn't here um
I don't think this was
noticing this
is well that's not there either
one is this not where they go are these
not SL
user can't remove them because they're
not there
um that file I would have thought would
have been
copied if I run this on the host
oops if I run this on the host it's
there right
so it's
there does not have the path to it
think this is actually it I just need
the
path still no
um I'm tempted to just use their Docker
file
options are do it on the
host or use their Docker
file I don't even the thing
is no it should render correctly through
the docker
file but I've got to cut losses here
this is like taking way too much
time I don't like the idea of having to
install all this crap on my host
it yeah see the thing is if I use their
Docker it's going going to be so old I'm
not going to be able to have puffer tank
running on
this I guess we're going to have to do
this on the base which is like that
sucks but
um that's what we got to do that'll only
like that shouldn't take me very long
that should hopefully make the thing
here
huh excuse me
have to
do I not have my user configured for
this yeah that's obnoxious
okay I don't like I don't know what's up
with the
systems permission to die with freaking
everything
where I don't even see where we're oh
here it
get
old I haven't worked on a base system in
so long
neim neim yeah very nice yeah we're not
doing
no this is cancer this is actual cancer
I'm not doing
this this is why I work on containers
right here this is actually so [ __ ]
stupid I don't know how people Dev like
this the python ecosystem is just
[ __ ] freaking virtual M to install
an
editor like I'm just gonna end up
breaking my base system with this like
crap old package
anyways can't even do
that um the problem is I'm not going to
be able to render this freaking thing
which is really
bad I honestly don't know what to do
about
that like I've spent enough time on this
I don't want to put this on a BAS system
install I'm going to need to have this
in a container
why those files are not getting copied
and
container their container is so
incredibly old
though I mean that's not going to be
good enough right
we know that the issue
is at least triggered from an internal
Vulcan
Library we know that there's some screw
with the
paths I don't want to just be working on
this thing all day is the problem like I
need to get the environment running like
there's Sim side stuff there's
observations I can't be doing this all
day
um that's so freaking bizarre that it's
just fundamentally break in a
Docker like why wouldn't the software
renderer work
software I don't even know how the
modern ones could possibly be worse than
this
I probably should have just like pushed
that but I don't know I had it on good
authority that the new ones are even
worse chat's 2 minutes slow
are you sure you're not just scrolled
back two minutes in the
video it's fastest on Twitch it
shouldn't be two minutes though
it's still freaking
Vulcan it's just like God
the Nvidia cannot open
file no such file or
it this should be on L this is on LD
Library path
right bit
GLX where is it expecting this thing
user
lib oh this is where it's expecting
okay so this is
here
Li okay it's just lib
egl so those are separate so these are
actually removed gxs is
here which we should
let me
so there
CP sir
lib user
lib six
there so it's got to be looking in the
wrong place
gxor
Nvidia yeah because this is absolutely
where it should
see now we have
this I check the Vulcan API
icd1 probably because I can't find that
file Library
okay this is one thing what if we give
it an absolute p
slash you know this is kind of
ridiculous unless is this
20 GS I I just typoed it
wait what JS
well I mean I've just manually copied a
bunch of files though so probably
something screwed up
um the question is why aren't any of
these files added
you need
to during the docker buildup hold
does this need to be done do or let me
see
does not need to be set it only needs to
specified at run
time okay so actually we should be able
to debug this
exist
okay whatever so this
runs and what do we have here user
lib lib
it literally tells me the same thing
five
times
stupid H the output here
I wonder if it's mounting them in a
different
spot okay hold on maybe this is needed
to get uh those additional
ah there it
is okay that actually gives us the
container
um that actually gives this to us okay
so this is better
now
okay this is actually good because the
thing is I'm going to need to have a
Docker working anyways with this so even
though this takes a [ __ ] ton of time and
it's a pain in the
ass um I need to get this
working there's not really a way around
it okay
so uh pull
render
want
pulen
info
VI error
unknown okay this is getting farther
than before at least
Nvidia what this
visible
devices
all and then Nvidia
case I'm starting to get hungry and I
got to run today
so uh we're going to have to do that
capabilities all visible devices all all
right
so
GPU
so okay the damn GPU finally shows
[ __ ] just you to that should not
freaking
matters I should add this to the tank
hold on
how much experience very little it's a
bad
algorithm the base of it at least I mean
I played with it
in 2016
like the base algorithm really doesn't
do very
much I mean Rainbow's kind of like
whatever three four five years worth of
improvements bolted onto
that in a very inelegant way
2.4.1 torch yeah so what we're going to
do is we're going to go to do puffer
what there a million different things
you could be masking
or inputs that are sometimes
not there why are inputs not
there dude what the [ __ ] is wrong with
this thing holy hell
okay well we can do something about that
we don't need the extensions for
um for
Isaac we'll
just you know
you got to be clearer about what you
mean by a missing input cuz there are
scenarios in which you mask missing
inputs but it sounds like you're
describing a situation that should not
happen well like what if my item isn't
there but the like I don't know what
you're referring to are specific
variables and the observations missing
is the entire observation Miss like
what's what is it
okay it's still trying to freaking
compile
this so my AI receives a bunch of inputs
that's the
observation eight of them are eight
possible items however it's unlikely the
AI will have eight
items is zero or should I include a
mask well the mask is just going to set
items to a specific value so unless
you're using zero to indicate something
specific then yeah it should it probably
should just be zero
you know it could be negative one if
you're actually using
zero you don't want it to be negative
infinity or something that'll just break
your
not right this [ __ ] is still somehow
running let me just
[Music]
depends on the data types of those items
as
well okay why is it still attempting to
compile
extensions I have no extensions there
are no extensions
include python.
[Music]
no okay as long as I'm not using
zero yeah you can but the thing is one
to six different item types those are
also going to get one hotted so yeah
what you would do is uh if 1 to six are
different item types and that's discrete
variable then you would have zero would
essentially be that like missing value
and then you would one hot it with the
seven unique different values so it
would become a Seven way discreet seven
way one hot it would turn into a length
seven Vector one hotted or alternatively
you would embed it into a fixed
Dimension like 32 or 64 which is
basically u i mean that that's the same
okay what is one hotted look that up
that's important you essentially uh if
you have like you have seven different
options 0 through six there so one hot
encoding you make a length seven Vector
you fill it with zeros and then you set
the index of the variable to a one so if
you have like if your variable's one you
set the second element to a
one and the rest zero
ah stupid
Me 3
231n I mean those two courses
right 231n 106 x
give you just like it'll just fill in a
bunch of random gaps that you've
got I mean that's like Baseline
knowledge to be able to teach yourself
other stuff and pick stuff up before you
have that you're kind of like you're
just you're missing tools in your
toolkit
I don't know it's like trying to do a
carpentry project but all you have is a
hammer and a screwdriver you're not
going to have a good
why are you installing torch
2.4.1
stupid I mean it shouldn't oh you know
why it is I cuz I'm
dumb on 3.8m pip
yep I swear it's like when I'm doing ual
Dev people get bored but when I'm
suffering through just horrible like the
worst
infrastructure stuff ever it's like oh
yeah that sounds fun uh this is 100%
breaking my container right here and I
have no idea
why I'm literally just going to have to
redo the container after this I'm sure
and then we'll have to go figure out why
the hell this has done
this torch should just be on the
container I don't know why it's doing
that oh wait never mind you know why
it's cuz uh it's a different python
version we're probably
fine yeah you know I probably should
have pushed to not work on this platform
but I've been told that Isaac Isaac lab
and the newer ones are even worse which
I mean I kind of doubt with how bad this
has been but you know who
on okay so now it no longer tries to get
torch I probably have to reboot the uh
the shell
and hopefully Cuda
works and hopefully Vulcan picks up the
GPU no
man I'm
uh about 10 years off of that
oops okay that actually does
work
type failed to load that's fine we know
what that is
okay so it immediately black screens but
it no longer seg
fults okay that's
progress this is progress we actually we
fixed the Vulcan mess so I'm probably
messing up the Sim or something
somehow but I fixed the horrible driver
hell
it was Docker container Flags Jesus
Christ Journal scripts haven't been
Loops
crazy okay um it's
11:46 I'm going to go for a run
I'm going to get some food I'm going to
do some exercise I'm going to get myself
in shape this has
been now
um what's this 20 hours of coding in the
last I don't even know 30 or something
but less than that
um I'm going to do that I'm going to get
myself restored a bit and I'm going to
come back and we're going to figure out
the rest of this mess um for folks who
are interested in RL that is much more
interesting than
this got tons of ultra high performance
reinforcement learning environments you
can play with right on our website this
is a trained agent playing this live
we've got them for most of these
games it's all free and open source you
can start the GitHub to help me out a
whole bunch for
free we've got a Discord with a ton of
people build and cool RL stuff if you
want to get involved we've got some
articles here on the blog and if you
want more
content there's some articles on my X
you can't find anywhere else and I post
a bunch of stuff about RL be back in a
few hours thank